une dizaine de licences n'ouvrira
finalement pas cette année dont six
devaient être proposées sur le pôle
martinique en septembre prochain
il s'agit des premières années de
licence arts licence histoire de l'art
licence sciences sociales licence
sciences politiques licence information
et communication et licence sciences
sociales au total près de 1000 lycéens
avaient envisagé l'une de ces formations
mais la présidence précise que seuls 173
en avaient fait leur voeu premier elle
ajoute que tout est mis en place pour
encadrer ces futurs étudiants
il faut qu'elle se rapproche des
composantes pour avoir des réponses et
des conseils une aide personnalisée pour
qu'ils puissent s'inscrire dans une
formation qui leur permettent ensuite à
partir de 2018 de pouvoir réintégrer le
cursus qu'ils avaient choisi
initialement il ya des passerelles qui
seront proposés l'ouverture de nouvelles
formations est soumise à accréditation
ministérielle des accréditations que
l'université des antilles n'a pas obtenu
pour la rentrée 2010 est
c'est un projet qui est ambitieux et
heureusement qu'il est ambitieux parce
que nous avons une ambition forte pour
ce pôle martinique à ce qu'il était il
et il n'était pas trop ambitieux mais il
est surtout il doit être en phase avec
les réalités économiques du pays
mais d'autre part vous savez que nous
avons
connu une période d'administration
provisoire nous avons connu une période
d'élections intense lui at elle voulu
aller trop vite en proposant une offre
de formation qu'elle n'était pas en
mesure de dispenser
quoi qu'il en soit les nouvelles
formations en iut et en os pe sont en
revanche maintenues pour la rentrée 2010
est l'université des antilles entend
ouvrir les autres licences en 2018